Chief Justice
John Roberts
has told the chairman
of the Senate Judiciary Committee
he won't testify before an upcoming
hearing on Supreme Court ethics.
That invitation to testify coming amid
growing scrutiny
about the ethical conduct
of the justices.
CNN's Brian Todd
is digging into all of this.
Brian, tell us more.
Right, Wolf,
that information on Justice
Roberts coming
now that we have new information
on a case that Harlan Crowe,
that mega-donor,
did have at least
a company
relating to Crowe
did have before the Supreme Court
a case that Justice
Clarence Thomas
did not recuse himself from
recently.
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
declared in a statement
that his dear
friend, Republican mega-donor
Harlan Crowe,
did not have business before the court
But tonight, CNN has learned
that's not true.
CNN's Arianna Devoe reports
a company related to Crowe
did have business
before the court in the mid to thousands
and just as Thomas didn't
recuse himself from the case.
There really was
a direct conflict of interest,
and it just makes the whole thing
a whole lot worse.
Records show that in January 2005,
a dispute
over a copyrighted
architectural drawing appeared
before the Supreme Court.
One of the disputing parties,
a company called Metric Holdings
Limited Partnership.
While Harlan Crowe's name
does not appear on a caption of the case,
a disclosure
statement says the corporate
parent of Metric Holdings
is Trammell Crow Residential Company.
A statement from Crowe's office
says the Crowe family at the time
had a non-controlling interest
in the Trammell Crow residential company.
The statement says
at the time of the case,
Trammell
Crow Residential operated
completely independently of Crow Holdings
and, quote,
Neither Harlan Crow
nor Crow Holdings
had knowledge of
or involvement in this case.
And Harlan Crow
has never discussed this
or any other case with the justice.
Also, the Supreme Court
declined to hear the case at the time.
Still, one
watchdog group is concerned when you have
an entity
that is connected to this person
who's given all sorts of favors
to justice, Thomas.
By the time
we're getting into
wholly owned subsidiaries
and exactly
who has a controlling interest
and who doesn't.
We're way past
the kinds of issues that create real
appearances, real problems
that the American people
would be concerned about.
Recent reports by the investigative news
outlet ProPublica
revealed that Justice Thomas
and his wife
Ginny accepted
luxury travel and gifts
from Harlan Crow for decades
and that in 2014,
Thomas sold three of his family's
Georgia properties to Crow.
Thomas didn't disclose
the real estate deal
and most of the travel in filings.
Thomas responded that he was advised
he didn't have to report the travel,
but a source believes
he will amend his filings
in the real estate deal.
Also tonight,
word of another potential
conflict of interest
with this beleaguered court.
Politico and CNN report that in 2017
a Colorado property
then co-owned by newly sworn in Justice
Neil Gorsuch,
was sold for nearly $2 million
to the CEO of prominent
law firm Greenberg Traurig,
a firm that had numerous cases
before the court,
including at least one
where
Gorsuch sided
with a ruling in favor
of the firm's client.
Records
show Gorsuch disclose
the sale of that property in filings,
but the section listing the buyer
was left blank
Neither the
Supreme Court nor
representatives for the firm Greenberg
Traurig have responded
to CNN's request for comment
on this reporting on Justice Gorsuch.
The CEO of that firm
who bought Gorsuch's property,
well, he told Politico
he's never argued any cases before.
Gorsuch
Clarence Thomas,
through a Supreme Court spokesperson,
declined to comment on CNN's
latest reporting on him.
And as we've just reported,
Chief Justice John Roberts
signaling no
interest, telling Senator Dick Durbin
he will not testify
before the Senate
and doesn't look like he's
going to investigate any of this Wolf.
All right. Brian Todd reporting for us.
Thank you very, very much.